[Música]
[Aplausos]
usa de manga longa eu era garçom
trabalha para ganhar um trocado era um
desespero pra ganhar dinheiro pagar
minhas contas está tudo atrasado
vengeance de banho tomado sete horas da
noite eu já estava no ponto
carregando uma bandeja até de manhã pra
ganhar 70 contra idéias atrasado que eu
recebi a pagar a minha conta o dinheiro
não via estava sem emprego mas não
conseguia eu não sabia o que fazia viu o
vídeo do pc siqueira achei interessante
e parte para o pátio para ver se fazia
sucesso era um olho na tela e o douro a
rua 15 anos eu saí de casa e tentar a
vida lá na capital foi a primeira vez
que eu fiquei sozinho semanas sem parar
à noite do natal pra crescer se que te
cunhão a nós do flash nem o do canhão
quem anda comigo sabe quem eu sou e que
foi difícil chegar melhor outras vezes
eu que um pedaço de pau eu não tinha
câmera dormia no chão tudo isso pra hoje
o teu inimigo número um da sua depressão
e pra quem vem de baixo 3 milhões é
pouco esse é um bom jeito no nordeste só
quebrada preste bem com deixe soltos
esse é o bonde do nordeste respeito o
bicho solto e 66 monem no país gravando
meu sempre sem ter microfones cheguei
bem longe agora por hoje eu posso ter
escrito o meu nome tá pupilos [ __ ]
questão de botar pra baixo atrás do
computador só de zé ruela guerra de
baixo
querem me derrubar só sabe falar não vou
me preocupar é sou muito ocupado e eu
acho que vocês estão maiores e casa e
pelos muçulmanos devem estar apaixonado
não liga o que eu passei também com quem
lutei ganhei foi derrotado também de
vocês em berço de ouro é só trabalhei
não me acho piada não me acho reinam mil
da dia sempre cheguei no futebol todo
mundo foi campo carro roubado após
assumir a lei a lei está na batalha
ninguém vai trabalhar no vasco não olha
aqui na varanda fogo de palha ele se
espalha e chega à serra da moça mas a
omni estraçalha você pilota na barreira
que a banda possa arrebentar todo
colocando tudo pergunta não sabe me
achando sai do mercado chegando passo é
boba no meio dessa gentalha assistiu
hilbert e fernanda lima também fechou e
eu também obra e ele conseguiu porque o
empate surgiu fluiu subiu e hoje
continua na batalha no sono quando
lutando chegamos em casa rima no plano
mandando quebrando vamo que vamo vamo de
costa falando no seu melhor pelo clube
quando foi derrubado por você continua
sujeito ficou chorando e chega animado
he-man 8 mil do meu nome estiver
chamados em prática não sei se é isso
mesmo mandou pro fundo que falei pra
você que a embalagem é só cabra macho
olha quem tá chegando é o bonde do
nordeste agag muçulmano aqui é só cabra
macho olha quem tá chegando é o bonde do
robert h
ele reforçou mano wilson nunes muçulmano
conexão árabe e nordeste tamo junto
eu queria agradecer a todo mundo que
ajudou esse canal a crescer e se você
faz parte do bonde clique em gostei
valeu como explodir o botão de likes